the trailer opens with this metronome
the same device that psychic medium
Elise Rainier used to hypnotize Josh
Lambert in the first Insidious so that
he could go into the further and rescue
his son the reappearance of it here
suggests that he'll be going back into
the further to settle some unfinished
business there's also a shot of someone
using a digital metronome propped up on
the side of a bet Dalton used to astral
project in his sleep before being
hypnotized to forget about his ability
at the end of Insidious chapter 2. I
cringe for this USB port but I would
guess that this is Dalton trying to
ReDiscover the mysteries of his past
were shown flashes of the family's past
in Insidious 1 and 2 before being taken
4 to 10 years with Dalton set to head
off to college to learn whose funeral
the family is attending what happens to
Josh over the years and what might be
hidden in each Insidious logo stick
around to the end of this video
[Music]
welcome to things you missed trailer
Edition today I'm looking at the first
trailer for insidious The Red Door since
the trailer glosses through things
pretty quickly I thought it would be a
good idea to go back shot by shot and
analyze what we're supposed to take away
from the trailer Insidious The Red Door
is the long-awaited follow-up to the
Lambert family Story the last two movies
were prequels exploring the past of
Elise so we never got to see what
happens after ghost Elise discovered the
red-faced demon haunting a new family
but we are definitely going to let's cut
in to the things you missed
at the end of the second movie Josh and
Dalton are hypnotized to erase their
abilities to astral project into the
further because of the danger associated
with it I've been saying for like 10
years now that this was not a good idea
because Josh forgot his ability when he
was a kid and this left him very
ill-prepared when his son demonstrated
the ability years later they would have
been better off learning to harness
their abilities like Elise sure enough
another 10 years go by meaning that the
red door is set in 2020. it seems like a
lot of movies just like to exist in a
universe where covid never happened for
some reason it's weird because I can't
really think of any movies set in say
like 1940s Germany that don't
acknowledge the Holocaust maybe the pain
from covid is just too fresh for
screenwriters to want to think about it
Josh is seen doing a memory exercise
where he flips over photos of his family
members he seems to be in a new house
and it's good to see that he got a new
armchair rather than keeping that one
that Elise died on it seems that he's
beginning to see ghosts again and his
nightmares have come back as a kid he
would astral project in his sleep which
he perceived as a series of nightmares
the shot where he wakes up is
deliberately framed so we don't see the
other side of his bed and in all of the
shots where he's at home he's alone
leading me to believe that he and Renee
may not be together anymore add that to
the fact that he's got all these photos
of her around the house and it makes it
look like he misses her Renee also
suggests that he Drive Dalton to college
to reconnect which may suggest that
they've been apart when driving Dalton
to college he's holding something
possibly some kind of cigar which would
also be a clue about his issues maybe
I'm totally over speculating but it's
possible that his memory issues are
connected to the relationship issues
with his family the only time he and
Renee are seen together is at this
funeral and speaking of which who died
the kids are grown up in this shot so
this isn't elise's funeral it's 10 years
later there are four characters who
don't appear in the trailer the
Paranormal Investigator specs and Tucker
elise's Ghost Hunter colleague Carl and
Josh's Mom Lorraine I'm guessing that
they're attending Lorraine's funeral
since they're probably not in contact
with Spex Tucker and Carl especially if
they potentially don't remember much of
what took place in 2010. her death would
be significant because assuming Josh and
Dalton lost their memories that would
leave Renee as the only one who truly
remembers everything that went on in
2010 and she'll be dealing with the
difficult quandary of whether or not to
remind them of those painful memories so
much you don't know when I was too
scared to tell you the truth okay so
Dalton is going to college for Art
School
you're old now no Dalton you're old now
interestingly in the trailer he says he
was in a coma when he was 10. in the
script of Insidious it suggests that he
was eight but as we know Aegis using
scripts are not canon he does look more
like he was eight in the original and it
would make sense if he was going to
college for the first time at 18. but it
could also make sense that he was 10 and
he started at a local community college
for the first two years and now 10 years
later he's 20 years old and transferring
away to University to study art Josh has
some kind of artwork in his house next
to his pictures of Renee which I'm
guessing is something that Dalton Drew
at some point it's fitting that he would
become an artist because he loved to
draw as a kid in fact his drawings of
what he saw in the further are what
caused his parents to realize that his
ability to astral project was real his
art teacher talks about balancing light
and dark in his compositions and there's
a double meaning here because light and
dark are terms sometimes used in this
franchise to describe the real world the
lights and the further the dark and we
see the beginnings of him drawing The
Red Door this suggests that it's
happening again some of the pictures he
drew as a kid were pictures of The Red
Doors that connect certain areas in the
further the art teacher tells him to
think deep into your memory
let's see what life can point so I would
surmise that his investigation into this
missing area of his memory causes his
astral projection ability to resurface
and causes the red-faced demon to have
another opportunity to possess Dalton's
body just as he had 10 years before in
one shot we see red face reach out and
grab Dalton's hand leaving a big gash
with no blood very similar to the injury
that at least sustained in the 1980s
when investigating Josh's paranormal
issues with the bride in black speaking
of whom when I first saw the trailer I
was confused because these are new
photos that we haven't seen before we
know the bride and black appears in the
background of photos taken of his
targets however I believe these are just
supposed to be old photos of Josh that
weren't shown in the previous movies an
Insidious 1 the photos are used to
explain to him what happened in his
childhood so that's probably what's
going on here again I don't think the
bride is back it would be pretty
disappointing if he came back because if
that were the case then what would be
the point of the second movie I do think
that they're going to be new photographs
that feature a different lurking entity
however Dalton meets a girl at college
and we see them take a selfie together
but the trailer doesn't show the result
of that photo however we do see familiar
things starting to happen like a red
handprint appearing on Dalton's bed
while Dalton was in a coma in 2010 the
family discovered something similar on
his bed sheet before all hell broke
loose we also see red face putting on
his favorite record by Tiny Tim and what
appears to be Josh and Dalton
approaching the red door and entering
red faces lair in Insidious as the
ghosts around the house started to smell
Dalton's empty vessel they got closer
and started appearing more frequently in
the real world one of them sticks a hand
out of a drawer as specs is closing it
in the new trailer we see something
similar a hand protruding out of a wall
like the other films they'll probably be
an array of ghosts outside the main
threat some good some neutral some evil
in this shot Dalton discovers someone
wrapped in plastic and if we bring up
the lights there's another creepy
looking figure in the distance there's
also a shot of someone aiming a
flashlight towards the demon and you can
see another entity moving around in the
background we also see a new entity
crawling out from under a bed it looks
kind of like this creature who was shot
for insidious the last key but
ultimately never featured in the movie
closer to the end of the trailer Dalton
gets dragged away with a chain on his
foot the same way he was confined by
redface and Insidious one additionally
it layers of this part where the adults
Dalton adult in if you will sees the
scene from the end of Insidious Chapter
2 of his dad who's possessed at the time
nearly about to strike him down with the
hammer remember one of the traits of the
further is that it's not tied to time in
the same way that our world is it can
show you different events from different
points in time since Dalton doesn't
remember the events of Insidious Chapter
2 he probably thinks this is real we
also see one of his paintings as a man
with a hammer standing in front of a red
door maybe a result of his foggy
memories of the second film we also see
The Return of the can phone in Insidious
2 this is how Dalton and Foster
communicated when they were supposed to
be in bed but it was later compromised
by the ghosts in the further trying to
communicate with Dalton he also used it
to his advantage in the end as a way to
find his way out of the further after
locating his dad as for Elise it seems
she's getting the old Randy Meeks
treatment this time around after her
death in the first Insidious she helped
out as a ghost in Insidious Chapter 2
claiming that she moved on to see a
better place which is implied to be the
equivalent of heaven but came back when
she realized that the Lambert family was
still in trouble
seen that better place
but I came back here because I heard you
calling and I think I can help chapter
two ends with her as a ghost joining
specs and Tucker on their investigations
although it appears that only little
kids can see her but after 10 years you
have to figure that she would have moved
on to that better place permanently
because there's no joy in staying in the
further plus she would probably want to
move on and be with her husband again
it's not clear if a ghost can come back
to the further after entering that
better place beyond the further at the
end of the trailer we see the Insidious
The Red Door logo this is actually
something I've been waiting for too
because I've spent probably too much
time thinking about the Insidious logos
starting with the second movie the
letters s i are colored red and I was
always curious if there was some meaning
there in the third one the three eyes
are red which seems to make sense it's
the third chapter and the three eyes
represent the Roman numeral three then
the last key logo actually looks
different in the trailer than it does on
the poster which made me question if
there is any pattern to this at all so
the new logo has the SI colored red once
again which I think may be an
intentional callback to the second film
this is the true follow-up to the
Lambert family story that we we've been
waiting for so its logo Will Follow That
of the second movie if that's the case
it's a lot simpler than I thought it was
going to be after a while I thought
there was going to be some secret
message there but I think that's all it
is before the new Insidious comes out
this July you need to get fully caught
up on your Insidious lore so check out
that playlist on the left I've got a ton
of Insidious content planned before then
so make sure you don't miss out on that
by subscribing to cz's world for new
Horrors every week ringing the death
bell for all notifications and I'll see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive